So-called libertarian Republican Senator Rand
Paul is now calling for Republicans to boycott
Coca-Cola. I know. I know. Why is he doing this?
Well, because Coca-Cola expressed an opinion
that the Georgia voter suppression
bill is bad. Here is Rand Paul
saying it on Fox News on Sunday. Take a look.
But my point is, yes, if they want to boycott us,
why don't we boycott them? This is the only thing
that will teach them a lesson. If Coca-Cola wants
to only operate in Democrat states and
wants only Democrats to drink Coca-Cola,
God love them. We'll see how they do when
half of the country quits drinking Coca-Cola,
when half the country quit using Delta.
Now, of course, half the country
won't quit flying Delta and half the country won't
quit drinking Coca-Cola, partially because people
are addicted to Coca-Cola, but partially because
these culture issues only play big in some circles
and most Americans don't care about them. Here's
another one. Republican Senate minority leader
just still gives me great pleasure to say
Senate Minority Leader Mitch McConnell.
He says corporations should stay out of politics.
It's unbelievable. I know. Now take a look.
And I found it completely discouraging to find
a bunch of corporate CEOs getting in the middle
of politics. My advice to the corporate
CEOs of America is to stay out of politics.
So the question for Mitch McConnell is, should
they also stay out of politics by not making any
political donations? Because if money is speech,
you're really speaking either way. And later,
Mitch McConnell was asked about it and he said,
oh, no, no, no, no, no, I'm not talking about
political donations, but think about that. I mean,
think about the hypocrisy. If money is speech,
when companies make political donations, they are
speaking. They are giving political opinions by
donating money to one or the other or both parties
or neither, but he says corporations need to shut
up, accept the money, which is speech according to
them. That doesn't need to stop. These people are
the biggest hypocrites at every single level. And
look look at the number of double standards that
there are when it's Chick fil A with a political
statement, they like it's speech. Corporations are
entitled to speak. They shouldn't be punished for
having opinions. The people saying boycott Chick
fil A are the ones that are in the wrong when
it's Coca-Cola with an opinion they don't like.
The view now becomes corporate CEOs should shut
up and stay out of politics, but not when it comes
to political donations where money is speech. In
that case, Mitch McConnell wants them very much in
politics donating to him. They're against council
culture. They're against boycotts when it's of Fox
News advertisers, but then they cheer when Fox
News runs a crawl with a list of companies that
took the wrong position on voting laws, which
we're going to look at in the next segment,
who is more pathetic and hypocritical than these
people? Now, I'm going to make a statement today.
I am committed to not changing my soda
consumption in any way as a result of this.
I have not had soda for like a decade other
than the occasional foreign coke. Yes,
foreign coke sweetened not with corn sirup, but
with sugar. I've probably had five foreign Cokes
in Latin America and Europe over the last ten
years. Otherwise I am committed to not making
any changes one way or the other to my
non-existent soda consumption as a result
of this. Now, just one other really funny thing
about this entire thing. They might be saying
boycott Coke without actually having any intention
or plan to do it. Case in point, new picture of
Donald Trump at his new office and his new desk in
Florida or Florida. Depending on your preference,
new picture has been published. If you look at
it carefully, you can actually see a Coke bottle
hidden behind Donald Trump's phone. So even
their stated boycott's they may not abide by
because they actually just like the product.
How ridiculous are these people? Completely and
totally pathetic. Abandoning their stated values.
They don't really care. It's all about avoiding
policy and fighting cultural issues. And Fox News
is now in on it, too. Let's talk about that next